[Music]
in crazy X news oh damn I don't have
raising X Asians submitted by cruising
down the street
mi6 for Wow a woman has been sentenced
to four to five years in jail for
stalking and harassing her ex-boyfriend
how many years was she stopped it's
about time I know you can go to jail for
it what was she doing then you need oh
but how good was that dick for you to be
stalking it like there like come on dude
I decide to stalk you baby I don't I
know I would stop Tommy it's so good be
a little more convincing please not the
same I think it's this like this maybe
this misguided kind of like oh I want to
I want to show like a grand romantic
gesture and I feel like a lot of
romantic comedies are actually really
harmful in that you know they kind of
send this message that you know if
you're just willing to fight for and you
just you know don't give up then you can
you know you can have you know the girl
the guy back I've never I've never
stopped to look at him does he look like
a stalker or get stopped here you know
what Ron JK news and it's time to be
honest but when I was when I was when I
was like 22 I was in a relationship and
it ended and I didn't want it to end and
I thought so you kidnapped her but I was
like I wanna I need to make a grand
romantic gesture because that will that
will fix everything you know I need to
show her how much I care
and so I I did a thing where I like I
showed up unannounced and like the way
that she looked at me when she opened
the door was like and that kind of said
it all for me and I and I kind of
realized in that moment how close I was
coming to like in a sock kinda like
behavior I mean I wasn't right I always
say the difference between romantic and
stalker is if they like your nuts mutual
yeah it's how much clothes yeah yeah so
I mean so from that point I mean that
that was a very very important lesson
for me too so that's good you want you
you got it immediately yeah
we would we would tend to give my kids
advice they go okay so what do girls
like it's like well they want guys to
you know show what they got and be like
persistent that only works if that
person likes you though bro it doesn't
work if they don't like you and it's so
weird that I have to mention that last
end but then how do they know if the how
do you explain it to a guy if a girl
likes your well girls a pretty clear
body language though yeah I feel like
right so if a girl doesn't feel even
when they say it like hard things it's
like oh yeah yeah yeah I can I feel it
you know I'm like hey how's it going
yeah yeah yeah yeah when I started
learning was when it became when it
started when things started to fall in
place so easily that's exactly what I'm
saying she pretends like there's effort
but there's not really because she can't
resist either yeah yeah like things are
just like oh you're free you're free a
lot you're around a lot and like it's
really easy to talk to you and you're
really engaged to me when we when we
speak and stuff like if you asked them
out and then they go oh I can't but I'm
free this day like they're like willing
to work because because they really want
to hang out - yeah yeah
yeah because it thinks if you say oh you
got some type of some coffee that I
can't tell time I don't like coffee and
then you come up with your response
which is well I could teach you alright
so this story is about Jessica who's 26
years old
with March so they were dating Jessica
moved from New York to London to work
alongside mark I don't know two works
Mike Sam but she ended up working next
to him in London the point is here that
he ended up breaking up breaking it off
with her and she just couldn't let him
go to a point where she was creating
fake email account sending them to him
and saying that someone raped kidnapped
and raped her and sending photos of her
like tied down in her oh my god and then
she also said that she was but she's not
posed all [ __ ] seductive she's just
like oh no they're gonna rape she's like
all makeup on her face and everything
yeah no no tears log lambda
she's got lighting and [ __ ] interfaces
like this okay
I now immediately regret I regret
starting off with like a sympathetic
angle because I was like oh let me
identify the root cause no no it's good
that was full-blown like right when he
broke over there she said that she was
pregnant and she ordered a fake
pregnancy belly from Amazon she like
continued to like play off as you know
why did I get one of those just to where
it's time he wants to feel what it's
like to be a mother
you could never have too many things
yeah that's you know I mean you can see
feeling like what a dad feels like I
could picture Bart with those like you
know those titties that you fill up with
milk oh my god what cities do you fill
up with milk the faked in your fake
breasts that dads cannot admit the
[ __ ] yeah the titty the fake the
plastic ones and then the the pregnant
ones the practice a pregnant peeing on
Amazon will never have sex ever again
uh-huh ever what if you start of
breastfeeding tyka you'll never have
center ever again and at the point too
late because you'll have the other baby
that's why he's doing here
Oh Daniel it's real that just looks like
me today I'll show you Jessica she looks
very nice she looks like a church camp
counselor yes sure he's the one that
looks crazy I mean what do they look
like today that's what they look like
today well this is what she looks like
now
how did she get younger easy a mugshot
she looks like she's like 17 here go
back she looks like she's 50 there
because of her hairstyle and go back
that looks like a picture from 1982 I
know so why we I don't know why she got
yeah so another thing she was doing is
sending text messages to his brother who
has children and saying like she's
keeping your children she's been the one
keeping your children safe it's just a
really bizarre a story crazy
where she was saying that the person who
kidnapped in and raped her was in a mi5
agent named max Brown a mission
impossible yeah five mi5 no you know mi6
is like the agency that it's like a
British mission impossible to I was like
no I found out that they have it up to
nine yeah like a whole bunch of
different ones anyway yeah I felt like
clearances their level just I don't know
anything about those bugs so she was
saying that max Brown handed her a
manila envelope containing photos of her
having sex with Mark oh wow and what is
that supposed to mean no idea this is
great problem dude these lies are so
extravagant like they're so crazy you
know what's crazy though we knew someone
that would say those extravagant
ass lies and people believed him but he
would say that he would say that he
worked for a special unit in the
military I believe though I believe that
so I thought it was funny too because we
would shoot guns with them and our
friend who's the army in the army
he shoots really good right and I'm like
isn't that funny both of you guys are in
the military and he sucks because he
wasn't doing good he couldn't back it up
he saw no I was like joking about it
yeah oh yeah you guys are both in the
military and he doesn't shoot like you
man you're [ __ ] good no at that point
no I was just like I feel pretty dope
because I shoot better than he would say
[ __ ] like yeah like I left I left the
spat that part now and like to
communicate to them that I'm no longer
with them I always carry a folded flag
in the back of my seat so if they ever
call me for another mission and they see
that and it communicates to them that
I'm not doing it anymore
we were like and his lies are very
casual and the stories are specific so I
think later on I found out his dad was
an Army Ranger he's probably using those
lies because they'll be something like
when he's down in here like they call my
name Bart Bart oh sorry uh we had a
grenade incident so I couldn't I can't
it's like that casual and that specific
so I just like and all these things add
it together you're like oh [ __ ] this guy
really wasn't some crazy [ __ ] before he
was smart like he's a really smart guy
and you're sorry you're still friends
crazy oh that's pretty that's pretty
intricate tonight you want to come
before the July nah nah no no I got PTSD
yeah yeah behavior oh yeah he'll put
PTSD post up you're like hey all my
fellow uh whatever veterans or people
that are in law enforcement if I know
how to feel some fireworks go off and
then it brings you to the dark place you
know heart
come over we could have our own whatever
I'm just like oh [ __ ] I mean I think
we've what can't we all know some people
who like are very elaborate storytellers
but I don't you're so nice you mean
liars elaborate story you are nice it's
you know in the land of Canada we're
very uh yeah you know that's so
interesting dude did I meet this guy
yo I'll tell you who it is afterwards oh
really
maybe I got duped to that huh anyway so
back to this story here I was like hey
hey yeah so I guess dead in 2009
Afghanistan I mean how are you going to
denies if they said that they did
military service you would be the
[ __ ] to say no you weren't that's it
that must have been the thinking is like
no who's gonna challenge me on yeah why
would you ever need to if he walked
outside he just went home is that the
brigade were safe I wonder how much more
you would have been like elaborate he
did alive well we know his girlfriend
right some of his stories were like so
he started taking steroids look you
don't want anyone else we had crazy like
bacne like he would just sit there back
acne I had to be in and he would he
would have a pimple that would just pop
and
into the white shirt pops on her face
you would like it would just be pop he
had he had like barnacles pretty much
all over his back and his girlfriend my
hair are you you're on here like what's
going on but taking all these deals all
I remember that one trip I told you I
was in Jamaica
ever since I swam in the water I came
back it's been like this what but
everyone ever Gimli what he said and he
said and we all lift we're all like no
that looks like steroid acne did but he
was like no adult onset acne but not
like that
you don't mean where you just get family
members no cousin that I'm curious about
like how does he play open lives in
front of them
he got caught are they still together no
okay yeah I don't know question do this
look good type that good date they makes
me laugh so what just think of like but
they have to stack like if you come up
with that one thing now all of a sudden
like you cannot hear anything out of it
it's almost like a character exercise if
you like you gotta like Daniel day-lewis
that because you're like okay I can
never hear out of this ear now what are
the rest of his life you want it you
want to laugh at something cuz so now we
have another friend whom we love dearly
okay that did a bunch of character work
just for the [ __ ] of it cuz he's a big
troll and he convinced his now-wife yeah
he convinced his now wife that he was
color blind for a year for no reason at
all just right right sister Wow yeah
that is awesome for the sake of comedy
that is but this guy wasn't trying to be
funny though right he's trying to be a
badass yeah he was a loser
oh did he'd like but he likes say this
stuff like nobody would ask him and he
would just voluntarily say like yeah
yeah there was a dude in high school
named Nick that used to do that all the
time like he was to say stuff like this
like we would just be chillin he goes
yeah man like so I got you know girl
broke well broke kids you know so when
somebody says they have like dope [ __ ]
didn't want to come over and see that
[ __ ] oh so we're poor kids and you said
you got that new Xbox or you got like a
[ __ ] like he had a scion tc at a time
to us that was a main control or a [ __ ]
everybody had like a broke-ass Civic oh
cool yeah I just put like this [ __ ]
turbo kid his [ __ ] fast we're cool
let's go over and see if he goes no I
can't do it return it yesterday oh my
god and I got to the point where he
would do [ __ ] like this he would say
stuff like this where he goes anyway
we're about to go do something you guys
you want to come in he goes nah man I
gotta take care of my my dog I was like
girl it's just throughout design you
guys got a dog's like no but are you
talking about and we come up there's
like you watch say you have a dog ah
yeah Wow
compulsive liar it was his other it was
his other personality it's so weird
because when he went to college so he
went to Davis right so which is really
close to Sacramento it turns out that he
lost all of his friends in Davis because
they caught him on the same [ __ ]
that he this week continued that [ __ ]
through college to Nick this is Nick so
yeah it was Nicholas yeah I bet you it
was another personality he forgot
Nicholas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]